um in the near future
uh technology is going to adapt to human
beings so they're going to start
understanding a natural language and not
only voice so voice is part of it and
also alexa and google home is one
application but obviously when you call
to the call center then not necessarily
a human being is going to answer the
phone
as i said voice is one aspect but also
texting and chatting and and the strong
belief that um well the way that humans
are going to communicate with interact
with technology is going to completely
transform to natural language interfaces
so i think that's why what drove me to
pursue this space so at least what
changed in my view and potentially it's
a bit controversial is that a virtual
assistants of virtual they're not humans
and hence they don't need to sound like
a human being or they don't need to act
like human beings they really need to
help you
focus on achieving the goal that you
want to achieve or to find the
information that you want to find so and
the
change that at least
i've been seeing is this focus around
goal completions rather than
sounding more
like a human being
i can tell you that again in healthcare
one of the
most significant
implementations that we've done
especially during 2021
was around automating uh conversations
to the call center around kobe 19.
um so
form you know i'm explaining people what
is this new disease
that's even back in 2020
uh to how they can protect themselves or
what are the symptoms and in 2021 it was
a lot about vaccinations eligibility
so new information that always came up
and and a lot of patients or people in
the world had a lot of questions about
them questions that this big health
networks couldn't answer just because of
staffing issues and we were able to
automate in in one implementation 85
percent of those interactions uh using
the virtual assistant um and and that
led to obviously like significant the
results both for the business and also
for the patients that
were looking for this information so let
me tell you a story that also helped me
like
um hone on on the idea of
conversationality so i told you we came
to the states so it was me and my family
back then we have a
one kid at the age of three about my
oldest son
and
we went on a on a road trip
and in the car
and then bow from his back seat
and shouted
and i let some play wheels on the bus
and and i was like what are you doing
because um
i'm like
for this kid he doesn't know what the
radio is
for this kid he just says or asks for a
song
and and the song plays automatically
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
twenty minute leaders is a proud
supporter of make-a-wish israel and tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthrate excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is about conversational ai and
i'm with israel brush
israel founded pyro in 2018 with the
goal of simplifying digital interactions
for patients by enabling providers and
payers to deploy conversational ai
interfaces at scale
since then he has raised over 15 million
dollars towards bringing that vision to
life building a team of 56 people in new
york california and tel aviv who serve
dozens of leading healthcare networks
including wheel cornell medicine mercy
health and novant health
before building jairo israel accumulated
over 15 years of experience in their
emerging technology space including
intel
starting out as a software developer
israel quickly moved up the ladder to
manage engineering and product teams in
various israeli startups and eventually
ascending to head of product at
a computer vision company which was
recently acquired by walmart
israel began his career in 8200 idf's
elite technology unit and holds an mba
from cornell university and a bsc in
computer science and statistics from tel
aviv university
[Applause]
four years ago you set out to
look at conversational ai and the way
that organizations and enterprises
interact in two-way conversations with
anyone really
what happened there why
why what is it about conversational ai
that that sort of sparked your curiosity
with an mba you're an engineer by
profession what what what was it
yeah so i think
it's uh you know it's a long story but
i'll try to make it as short as possible
so throughout my career from 8200 to
being in a bunch of startups
i was fascinated with what's known today
as a hci so human computer interaction
um and i can tell you that in some of my
previous roles i was a software engineer
and product manager trying to understand
how we humans communicate with
technology and with screens and mobile
applications and websites and so on and
so forth
and then as you said i moved to the
states to get my mba
and you know during this transition i
got exposed to alexa and google home
that was back in 2017. so this all a
nice voice
um assistant that they found the way to
our homes basically
so i got fascinated by them got very
excited
almost immediately very disappointed i
would say with the lack of sophisticated
use cases that they can solve
but i became obsessed with this notion
that
in um unlike in the past where we needed
to adapt ourselves to communicate with
technology so to become familiar with
websites and structures of websites and
mobile applications and and all of and
various gestures you know like pinching
and tapping and in the near future
technology is going to adapt to human
beings so they're going to start
understanding a natural language and not
only voice so voice is part of it and
also alexa and google home is one
application but obviously when you call
to the call center then not necessarily
a human being is going to answer the
phone uh so i said voice is one aspect
but also a texting and chatting and and
the strong belief that um well the way
that humans are going to communicate
with interact with technology is going
to completely
transform to natural language interfaces
so i think that's why what drove me to
pursue this space
and luckily for me i met my co-founder
at connelltech he did his masters in
computer science and we actually met in
the machine learning class and nothing
related to the mba just something that i
was able to take
because of my background and and that's
how we started the high row
incredible and so as you're now you're
you're four years and to ride a little
bit more than four years into high rope
where are you today in terms of your
in your relationship with conversational
ai has this
understanding changed has your passion
changed throughout the last four years
as you've been diving more and more into
it
yeah absolutely okay i i think
absolutely so i think that
one of the main changes that at least
myself myself is how practical i'm
trying to be and when it comes to what
type of problems the conversational ai
is trying uh to help us with uh to add
to human weapons so there are a lot of
different
you know companies in the world that are
tackling various aspects of
conversational ai
so some of them for example attack and
the speech recognition or the speech to
text the type of aspect while many
people think that this is almost a
solved problem it's actually really far
from it and and we see it especially
again when we try to automate
conversations in the call center but
that's not where we focus we focus on
the natural language understanding about
on the nlu path
and and for that we're trying to become
very much a goal oriented so i would say
that something that changed dramatically
at least in my view is that virtual
assistants are
virtual they are not a humans right so
um
at least you're probably familiar with a
bunch of uh
of of
implementation such as maybe google
duplex which has this nice demo of a
human-like type of interaction including
uh
pauses like
when thinking so at least what changed
in my view and potentially it's a bit
controversial is that virtual assistants
of virtual they're not humans and hence
they don't need to sound like a human
being or they don't need to act like
human beings they really need to help
you
focus on achieving the goal that you
want to achieve or to find the
information that you want to find so and
the
change that at least
i've been seeing is this focus around
goal completions rather than
sounding more
like a human being
now from from the industry perspective
what what what is this is the impact of
conversational ai in your in your eyes
as we're developing these solutions so
where you know why is this something
that companies should should adopt or
should even think about taking today in
in 2022
yeah so i think that uh
so high low operates in in multiple
verticals but the two main ones today
are healthcare and the real estate and
in healthcare especially with
covenanting in the best two years i
think that if they realize
the contact center problem or at least
like it become much more clear to them
and so they were getting
three x the volume sometimes even 10x
the volume of chords that they were
getting beforehand and they simply
couldn't answer um all of their calls
and now you as a consumer
probably are familiar with the long
waiting times
that is something that you know in this
digital world should be belong to the
past
everyone wants to get the information as
fast as possible as immediate as
possible and without waiting for an
agent online 24 7
from everywhere even like while texting
so i think that they both like the
the new expectations by by consumers by
patients as well as
the operational inefficiencies
of these organizations on the contact
center that drove a lot of them to
seek for conversational ai solutions
mostly to automate a lot of these
interactions and become a more
operational efficient
uh
i can tell you that again in healthcare
one of the
most significant
implementations that we've done
especially during 2021 was around
automating uh conversations to the call
center around copy 19.
um so
form you know
i'm explaining people what is this new
disease that's even back in 2020
er to how they can protect themselves or
what are the symptoms and in 2021 it was
a lot about vaccinations eligibility so
new information that always came up and
and a lot of patients or people in the
world had a lot of questions about them
questions that this big health networks
couldn't answer just because of staffing
issues and we were able to automate in
in one implementation 85 percent of
those interactions uh using the virtual
assistant
and and that led to obviously like
significant their results both for the
business and also for the patients that
were
looking for this information
well and from the consumer's perspective
how do you see people not responding to
conversational ai chatbots virtual
assistants what what's been know do they
treat it as a human do they
you know are they playful with it do
they trust it
yes so in 2022 you know the initial
reaction is agent agent right this is
the initial reaction and then for a good
reason you know like until now when most
chatbots voice assistants kind of sucked
um to to be completely honest and that's
what we're trying to change and however
however
uh
there are organizations today
that will not give you access to a live
agent without for example identifying
you first
and and and understanding your status so
if you call bank of america
there's no way you're going to get to an
agent uh
unless you
give
information about yourself then and they
actually identify you as a member and
only then you might get to an agent and
that's out of an actual need right so if
you want to talk with the bank and you
don't want to get there physically you
will talk with this virtual assistant
whether you like it or not and i can but
but this is maybe the extreme case um
let's take a another case in the real
estate the market so let's say you found
an apartment apartment that you really
like or a property or community that you
they really want to check out and and
you know it's a crazy market so you want
to schedule a tour as fast as possible
but you saw it at 10 p.m what would you
prefer you would prefer to wait for 8
a.m the next morning or talk with this
virtual assistant that might not
understand you as well as a human being
sure but if it's good enough it will be
it will be able to actually get your
details and schedule a tool for you for
the next day immediately so i think it
really depends on what you're trying to
achieve and what are
your other options
yeah
but obviously technology is progressing
right we've seen the the recent
advancements of large language models in
uh
and i'm personally i've been following
google duplex
as a fan banned for since its inception
well we will get to an inflection point
where you're talking to an agent and
you're not sure whether it's a real
person or if it's a virtual agent
how does the world change at that moment
so obviously you're going to be at that
intersection because you will be
leveraging that that cutting-edge
technology and you already implemented
it with all of these enterprises and
these right so you will be the enabler
who is sort of
making it happen how how how is it how
are things changing if at all
you know i think that like
a lot of different areas where
technology advancements
lead to us
human beings having more
time to do some more complex tasks
because we don't need to focus on things
that now we get for free so let's take a
waze as an example or like gps as an
example
once at least i remember myself going on
a trip on a road trip with a map
memorizing
routes and and and then figuring out
what's the best way to get to somewhere
and that's something that they don't
need to do anymore that's it like period
it's it's in my phone i tap it i don't
think about it and now i have one more
hour to maybe
plan like a nice game with the kids
right uh because i don't need to plan
this uh trip so why do i give you this
analogy because uh for example on the on
the customer success or customer support
type of teams um instead of fans
answering like the same
uh
i would say repeating the easy question
that people can find online like what's
your opening hours and how can i get
there and do you have a parking spot
and even like scheduling appointments so
as i gave the example of scheduling a
tour with a with a property that you
like humans won't need to do that and
and that will leave them a lot of time
to focus on things that computers will
have had time to accomplish so for
example okay you know
talking about the mischarge right like
that's something that even an agent will
take a lot of time to realize whether
like this complaint is actually
justified or not and they will need to
open a ticket and whatnot so what what i
believe will happen is that
especially in these contact centers for
support and success
the human agents will be tasked and
focused on on a much more complex set of
tests and will
and will have much more time to deal
with
humans whereas the virtual assistants
will take the more
mandated repetitive tests and now i can
have a lot of like you know interesting
discussions around well what happens
when virtual assistants talk with
virtual assistants actually our virtual
assistant a couple of times talked with
the google duplex assistant and that was
quite funny
so a lot of possibilities in this new
world um and also gives me a lot of new
challenges
it's interesting because you what you
were mentioning before about waze and
you were basically describing
this idea of adaptability right that
that we humans we will adapt and you
know we you know you probably when you
were using a map it was very hard to
conceive of a world where you're
definitely not going to need to
to do a to to spend any of that time
there
you know i'm thinking for myself i never
used the map right i grew into a world
so i'm thinking even for this new
generation for them
talking to a real agent would be almost
silly what do you mean we had to speak
to physical people to to to get care of
our tasks and to give us information
that an algorithm can find right
so so let me tell you a story that also
helped me like
on the idea of conversationalize so i
told you we came to the states so it was
me and my family
back then we have a
one kid at the age of three a bang my
oldest son
and
we went on a on a road trip
and in the car and then bow from his
back seat
and shouted
and i let some play wheels on the bus
and and i was like what are you doing
because
and like for this kid he doesn't know
what the radio is
for this kid he just says or asks for a
song
and and the song plays automatically
he doesn't care that it's a physical
device that that his dad bought it best
buy for for all he knows he says to the
world alexa play a song and it plays
correct correct exactly and i think that
we talked about like the demands of of
the consumers constantly changing so
thinking about the next generation it
it's really crazy
to think about
in their expectations from technology
and form
again the technology to be able to
understand them and you look the other
way around
incredible i love it and so today with
jairo tell me a little bit about you
know where you find where you where you
fit in as the ceo so not necessarily
where jairo is but but where is israel
in this whole thinking process what are
you most excited about today
uh
yeah i think that one i'm very much
excited when things happen in the
company without me knowing it so
you know the company at the stage of
like three people 10 people 20 people
you know everything you're in the
details in in in each and every one of
uh
the the epics and and jira tasks and
customers and today we have an executive
teams and we have team leaders and we
had a lot of super talented people that
are just advancing the company forward
and and that really excites me and i
think that me as a ceo in this company i
i care about like three main things one
is the vision alignment so and and i'm
constantly
learning how hard it is to align
everyone on the same vision and how many
times you need to repeat it and make
sure that like what's in in this head of
of mine that is based on you know
experience from the past four years or
so and gets to everyone in the company
um so we you know we move together
towards like this
very clear path this is like everyone is
pulling uh to to a different direction
so that's a that's a one thing that i'm
really spending a lot of my time on uh
the second thing is making sure that we
have amazing people in the company
and that means both to get them on board
and then to create the culture to
actually make sure that they're
constantly you know challenged
professionally and have a good time you
know personally and obviously i'm not
doing it alone but i think that
i don't know if culture you know
we're less than a 60 people team so
culture is a very big world for me
still
but
maybe creating this dna of like similar
people that are enjoying working
together and that are constantly feeling
challenged professionally and and
finally you know the the the
uh the first thing that i'm doing as a
ceo in this company uh is making sure
that the company has money so
it's both on the fundraising front but
also
being strategic with customers and
controlling the budget
and so i'm looking
to understand you know where you know if
you
you know if before you go to sleep or
when you wake up you know
when your mind wanders does it wonder
more towards the
the technology or the consumer behavior
shift that you're creating does it go
more towards the health of the company
and the growth of the company where
where is israel in this whole eco
chamber now and i'm sure it's all of it
but but i'm wondering you know in the
really core of israel
where does your mind go
right so obviously you know
in the last couple of weeks i want to
say we are we are going into a
completely different market right like a
downturn a potential recession
so a lot of my mind is dedicated to
how do we stay alive while our
competitors are going to die
um and not only to stay alive but how we
can actually assess this opportunity
when a lot of them die
to capture a larger market share and so
it's uh
that's where my head's at and obviously
that's also reflect on on the fact that
today i'm much more go to market driven
and execution driven right uh
however
i think that
it is as you said all connected
so um in order to
you know capture a large market share
especially in this market you need to
have some sort of a an unfair advantage
and a lot of the time you know from uh
companies that come from israel uh it
comes from the technology aspect so
building a very unique technology that
that allows you to get this unfair
advantage but i i constantly think about
how it serves the business like how can
i prove that this unfair technology
um serves the business purposes hence we
are executing much better well capturing
more market share uh than others and so
on yeah i don't know if it fully answers
your answer your question but
i i definitely feel that i'm a little
bit better inside your head and and i
really enjoyed this episode israel 20
minutes go by fast but i i really love
the work that you're doing with
conversational ai and thinking about
consumer behavior and market shifts and
it can to be easy being the ceo of a 60
person company in in today's world and
you have to both deal with the emerging
technologies and and go to market
strategies and educating the market
while keeping track with what's
happening in the most cutting-edge
research at the same time you have to
deal with the market that is basically
telling you that it's a complete
opposite of what it was a four months
ago and so a interesting challenge and i
look forward to seeing how you deal with
both of these aspects and so thank you
very much for being here
thank you megan for having me it was a
pleasure thank you
[Music]